there is no company  that is massive today no Society no no  country  that at one point the original founders  of that country of that Society of that  company  had sleepless nights and did stuff that  made no sense in regards to work to get  it to where it's at today there isn't  any you tell me stories of actors you  guys want to go after Twitter why don't  you go talk to actors how many of them  work 20 hour shifts and yes Sac has to  pay them the overtime how many actors  you know so how was it working dude I  just have to sit there and they just  call me man I could be at any time I can  do this and we got to be up one time we  did this 24 hours one time we did that  18 hours  go talk about military you know how many  nights we would sleep like how many  times oh during 9 11 I was sleeping on a  rock a rucksack was my 36 hours one time  we did I'm like you seriously yeah we  have to do this you got to get used to  because if you can't do this how are you  gonna handle in war